good afternoon to everyone
these are stressful emotional times as
we know and today is a day in the state
of New York
with very mixed emotions based on two
very different pieces of information we
have I'm trying to work through the
mixed emotions for myself so I'll just
present the facts and then we'll go from
there there is good news in what we're
seeing that what we have done and what
we are doing is actually working and
making a difference
we took dramatic actions in this state
we New York pause program to close down
schools businesses social distancing and
it's working it is flattening the curve
and we see that again today so far
meaning what meaning that curve is
flattening because we are flattening the
curve by what we are doing if we stop
what we are doing you will see that
curve change that curve is purely a
function of what we do day in and day
out but right now it's flattening the
number of patients hospitalized is down
and again we don't look at just
day-to-day data you look at the
three-day trend but that number is down
the three day average trend is also down
anecdotally there were individual
hospitals the larger systems are
reporting that some of them are actually
releasing more people than are coming in
so their net down so we see the
quote/unquote flattening of the curve we
have more capacity in the hospital
system than ever before so we've had
more capacity in that system to absorb
or more people the sharing of equipment
which has been really one of the
beautiful cooperative generous acts
among different partners in the
healthcare system has worked if the
hospitalization rate keeps decreasing
the way it is now then the system should
stabilize over these next couple of
weeks which will minimize the need for
overflow on the system that we have
built in at jabots and that the USNS
comfort so that is all good news there's
a big caution sign that's if we continue
doing what we're doing if we continue
doing what we're doing we are flattening
the curve because we are rigorous about
social distancing etc so if we continue
doing what we're doing then we believe
the curve will continue to flat but it's
not a time to get complacent it's not a
time to do anything different than we we
have been doing remember what happened
in Italy when the entire healthcare
system became overrun so we have to
remain diligent we have to remain
disciplined going forward but there's no
doubt that we are now bending the curve
and there's no doubt that we can't stop
doing what we're doing that's the good
news the bad news isn't just bad the bad
news is actually terrible highest single
day death toll yet 779 people when you
look at the numbers on the death toll it
has been going steadily up and it
reached a new height yesterday the
number of deaths as a matter of fact the
number of deaths will continue to rise
as those hospitalized for a longer
period of time pass away the longer you
are on a ventilator the less likely you
will come
the ventilator doctor foul Qi spoke to
me about this and he was acted percent
right the quote-unquote lagging
indicator between hospitalizations and
deaths the hospitalizations can start to
drop the deaths actually increase
because the people who have been in the
hospital for 11 days 14 days 17 days
passed away that's what we're seeing
hospitalizations dropped and the death
toll rises I understand the science of
it I understand the facts and the logic
of it
but it is still incredibly difficult to
deal with every face every number is a
face right and that's been painfully
obvious to me every day but we have lost
people many of them frontline workers
many of them health care workers many of
them people who were doing the essential
functions that we all needed for society
to go on and they were putting
themselves at risk and they knew they
were many of them vulnerable people who
this this vicious predator of a virus
targeted from day one this virus
attacked the vulnerable and attacked the
weak and it's our job as a society to
protect those vulnerable and that's what
this has always been about from day one
and it still is about be responsible not
just for yourself but to protect the
vulnerable be responsible because the
life you risk may not be your own those
people who work into and walk into an
emergency room every day and put
themselves at peril
don't make their situation worse don't
infect yourself or infect someone else
so their situation becomes more
dangerous just to put a perspective on
this 911 which so many of us live
through in this state and in this nation
2753 lives lost this crisis we've lost
sixty two hundred and sixty eight New
Yorkers I'm going to direct all flags to
be flown at half-mast in honor of those
who we have lost to this virus big
question from everyone for my daughters
I'm sure around most people's dinner
table when will things go back to the
way they were I don't think it's about
going back I don't think it's ever about
going back I think the question is
always about going forward and that's
what we have to deal with here it's
about learning from what we've
experienced and it's about growing and
it's about moving forward well when we
will we return to normal I don't think
we return to normal I don't think we
return to yesterday where we were I
think if we're smart we achieve a new
normal the way we are understanding a
new normal when it comes to the economy
and a new normal when it comes to the
environment now we understand the new
normal in terms of health and public
health and we have to learn just the way
we've been learning about the new normal
and other aspects of society we have to
learn what it means global pandemic how
small the world is actually gotten
someone sneezes in Asia today you catch
a cold tomorrow
whatever happens in any country on this
globe can get on an airplane and be here
literally overnight and understanding
this phenomenon and having a new
appreciation for it how our public
l-system has to be prepared and the
scale to which we need a public health
system look at the way we're scrambling
right now to make this work we have to
learn from that I think we've also
learned positive lessons we found ways
to use technology that we never explored
before you have a New York state court
system that thank you chief judge is
basically developing a virtual online
court system which has all sorts of
positive benefits going forward using
technology for health care using
technology work from home using
technology for education I think these
are all positives that we can learn
testing capacity which we still have to
develop that is going to be the bridge
from where we are today to the new
economy in my opinion it's going to be a
a testing informed transition to the new
economy where people who have the
antibodies people who are negative
people who have been exposed and now are
better those are the people who can go
to work and you know who they are
because you can do testing but that
we've all developed a sense of scale
over the past few weeks in dealing with
this
there's also lessons to be learned why
are more African Americans and Latinos
affected we're seeing this around the
country now the numbers in New York are
not as bad as the disparities
disparities we see in other places
across the country but there still are
apparently disparities why well
comorbidity I understand that but I
think there's something more to it you
know it always seems that the poorest
people pay the highest price why is that
why is that
whatever the situation is the natural
disaster Hurricane Katrina the people
standing on those rooftops were not rich
white people why why is it that the
poorest people always pay the highest
price but let's figure it out let's do
the work let's do the research let's
learn from this moment and let's learn
these lessons and let's do it now we're
going to do more testing in minority
communities but not just testing for the
virus let's actually get research and
data that can inform us as to why are we
having more people in minority
communities more people in certain
neighborhoods why do they have rate
higher rates of infection I get the
comorbidity I get the underlying illness
issue but what else does it play are
more public workers Latino and
african-american who don't have a choice
frankly but to go out there every day
and drive the bus and drive the train
and show up for work and wind up
subjecting themselves to in this case
the virus whereas many of the people who
had the option just absented themselves
they live in more dense communities more
urban environments but what is it and
let's learn from that and let's do it
now
I'm going to ask our SUNY Albany chief
dr. Avadon Rodriguez that had an effort
to do it right now we'll do more testing
in minority communities now with more
data research done now so let's learn
now Department of Health will be doing
it along with north well but let's learn
these lessons now we're also going to
make an additional six hundred six
hundred dollar payment to all unemployed
New Yorkers the federal government says
they will reimburse us for it but people
need money now in their pocket so New
York will be doing that immediately
we're also extending the period covered
by unemployment benefits for an
additional 13 weeks because from 26
weeks to 39 weeks so that should be a
relief on voting I've seen lines of
people on television voting in other
states as is totally nonsensical
god bless them for having such diligence
for their civic duty that they would go
stand on a line to vote but people
shouldn't have to make that choice and
we're by executive order all New Yorkers
can vote absentee on June 23rd primaries
coming up I want to say thank you to the
many places and people who are working
with the state of New York
mercury Medical donated 2,400 BiPAP
machines BiPAP machines are technically
not ventilators but they can be modified
to effectively ventilate even though
they're not ventilators and we're using
them they were brought up from Florida
thank you very much JetBlue for doing
that I also want to thank Oregon and
Washington State in California for
freeing up ventilators I want to thank
the direct care workers who are doing a
fantastic job and they're doing it every
day I want to thank the state workers
who are showing up and doing a great job
every day every first responder this has
been a long battle and it's going to go
on but I want them to know how thankful
we all are of them for what they're
doing I want people to remember that
we're flattening that curve and if
anything we doubled down now on our
diligence we're going to start a social
media campaign who are you staying
home for right is not about staying home
for yourself stay home for others stay
home for the vulnerable people who if
they get this virus are in a really bad
place in life stay home for the health
care worker who's in the emergency room
because you don't want to infect anybody
else who then puts another greater load
on our healthcare system so who are you
staying home for I'm staying home for my
mother but everyone it's not about just
you it's about all of us so who you
staying home for and we'll start a
social media campaign that does that but
thank you to all the New Yorkers for all
they've done and we still have more to
do we are by no means out of the woods
and do not miss read what you're seeing
in that data and on those charts that is
a pure product of our actions and
behavior if we behave differently you
will see those numbers change I just
doubled the fine on disobeying the
social distancing rules why because if
anything we have to get more diligent
not less diligent and we have more to do
and that's New York tough but tough is
more than just tough tough is smart and
disciplined and unified and tough is
loving the toughest guys are tough
enough to love right last point our
brothers and sisters in the Jewish
community celebrate Passover tonight
we wish them all a Happy Passover the
Jewish community has had a long and
difficult year besides any of this the
number of incidents of anti-semitism
across this country the violence that
they have seen even in this state of New
York that has such a large Jewish
population so we wish them all well on
Passover and the message of Passover I
know helps me today and I offer it to
others to consider Passover says we
remember the past we learn from the past
we remember the lessons of the past we
teach a new generation those lessons but
there's also a message of hope in
Passover next year in Jerusalem in
Jerusalem next year will be better yes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah question is many of the essential
workers public workforce tends to be
african-american and Latino I think
that's probably right I don't know the
statistics but I think that's probably
right I also believe the frontline
workers do have a greater exposure than
most people I think that's one of the
things we'll find when we do this
research and why is the infection rate
higher with the african-american
community and the Latino community again
the disparity that we're seeing in New
York is nothing like what you see in
other places across the country but I
think it is something that we have to
understand I don't think we can reduce
the essential services you know we're
down to basically food pharmacy basic
transportation which frankly is more for
our essential workers to get where
they're going if you would if you didn't
have public transportation you couldn't
have those health care workers showing
up you couldn't
the grocery workers showing up so I
don't think we're in a position to say
eat less or use less drugs or use less
healthcare I think we have to get
through this now and then learn from it
and see what we what changes we can make
in the future
second Karen just burped sorry just the
state slowed to shut everything down did
New York pause come too late
do you guys wish that you had started
reducing the workforce shutting down
businesses etc sooner especially
considering San Francisco had shut down
prior to New York do you think that New
York was late to act no no I think New
York was early and I think the actions
we took were more dramatic than most and
frankly were criticized as being
premature so no I think if you could
rewind the tape you'd have to go back to
last November December what was going
around what was happening around the
world and what was the effect going to
be here my point about you know global
pandemics we're watching China we're
watching Italy we're watching other
countries well extrapolate from that on
a national basis I was the first part of
your question Bernadette just wondering
if you think you know should you have
shut down the schools there there's a
conflict between the city schools you
know de Blasio and you were having that
debate over should we shut them down
also bars and restaurants should any of
those actions been comfortable you know
there was there wasn't a debate I made
the decision to close down the city
schools there was there was I didn't
have a debate there was a debate about
closing City Schools and people thought
I closed the city schools prematurely
that was the ongoing debate but no I
think look of anything in retrospect it
shows what we did is right I'm sorry cam
on the June 23rd phony do you envision
polling places being open with everybody
I think we're just saying absentee
voting is an option we don't say it's a
necessity right we're saying absentee
voting is an option we're saying the
temporary illness provision of the
absentee voting will include the risk of
contracting kovat 19 and I think we're
gonna take a wait-and-see approach as we
get closer on whether or not any poll
should be open the Connick landing is a
nursing home that has been releasing
data should other nursing homes be
releasing data is the question should
all nursing homes or any nursing homes
so we are tracking the nursing homes and
and we we want to protect the privacy of
the individuals in the nursing homes and
we do defer that back to the homes
themselves so that particular place has
released data but we do track it we have
seen in multiple nursing homes across
the state particularly in the lower down
state I should say cases and we do track
them some of them are as a result of one
person who was there and and others have
gotten infected so we are looking at
that closely patients like other states
and countries have well again it goes
back to the fact that the nursing home
is in many ways their where they live
it's not like where you go into the
hospital then you can leave the hospital
so we try to protect their privacy a
little bit more but we do keep we do
track and if there's a case there of as
a concern there we go and investigated
immediately it would be shut down until
June 7th this morning is that going to
be a good rule of thumb for other sorts
of mass gatherings in New York City or
statewide No
I wouldn't use what they think mass
gatherings beginning before Jules I
don't know I don't know but I wouldn't
use what Broadway thinks as a barometer
of anything unless they're in the public
health business and they have seen
better numbers and models I think look
all of these projections basically
turned out to be wrong right and this is
a very hard thing to model because
besides all the variables you're
modeling public behavior and what people
will do if you go back and you look at
even models that were put out in January
they all had a premise about how
effective social distancing would be
what percent of the population would
actually comply with social distancing
etc and they have turned out to be wrong
but I think Jessie they can be wrong
either way you know I'm more worried
about people saying oh well the number
of cases is coming down it's now safer
it's not it's not I'm more afraid of the
number changing and the curve changing
because people read something into it
that's not their if you reduce that
compliance on social distancing you'll
see those numbers go up within days
literally go up within days so no I take
it one day at a time look at the data
for the day look at the numbers for the
day and then make a decision well two
weeks there look we only went to April
29th right with the school closing we
extended everything until April 29th on
the school closing New York pause even
that's a projection
I wouldn't go past that
concentrations of Malaya and Stephen
downstate Hudson Valley but there are
other places where you haven't seen
cases you foresee open schools haven't
seen these cases yet Jimmy and be
careful of tents and be careful of
counting our chickens before they hatch
we haven't seen cases yet we are in the
midst of this don't start doing a
retrospective like it's over because
that's the attitude we have to avoid you
will see more cases in upstate New York
I'll bet you whatever you want to bet
right now you will see more cases on
Long Island I'll bet you whatever you
want to bet right now so we're not
thrilled it's not over we are in the
midst of it we have some good news in
that what we're doing is working and by
the way we've all been killing ourselves
right one way or the other
isolation the work of the health care
system has been phenomenal people
working 24 hours a day people exposing
themselves the good news is that's
showing a benefit and flatten the curve
at a lower rate than almost any of the
models were projected okay that's the
good news but we are still in the midst
of it and the bad news the terrible news
is look at how many lives we lost I mean
it is breathtaking so the next time we
want to think about we're getting a
little complacent or cavalier look at
the number of people we've lost remember
that before you decide to go out of the
house because you have cabin fever
what what metric would you be looking at
or dr. Zucker or any of you to make that
sort of decision what would be the
tipping points of the infection rates
Jessie that number has to come down on
the other side of the mountain the
number of infection new cases going to a
hospital the infection rate has to come
down to a point where you believe the
isolation of the vulnerable the other
measures we're taking
is enough to start to reopen and then
how do you reopen it's not just gonna be
about Broadway theatres before you go to
Broadway theatre spearguns everyone can
go back to work when can I go back to
school one of the other essential
services going to open you know before
they go to a play there's gonna be a lot
of other questions that they're gonna
ask and that's gonna be a function of
numbers frankly I would like to do that
on a regional basis with Connecticut in
New Jersey because this is a regional
workforce so I stay very close to the
governor Murphy and governor Lamont on
those decisions I don't believe in these
geographic distinctions in these
situations right there is no New York
City there's New York City there's
Nassau the Suffolk there's Westchester
this Rockland right the virus doesn't
stop at a border and these these
decisions are regional in nature
so now Broadway obviously is a microcosm
but the overall decisions are all in a
regional context and I think it's going
to be the numbers and when are the low
numbers low enough that it is safe
wouldn't need to be zero is what you're
saying it could just be lowered yes yes
I don't have to be zero I don't think it
may never be zero it may never be zero
and you have to watch this you know when
we go back to normal you think is not a
you think this is ever gonna be a
morning that I wake up again in my life
not worried about this in the back of my
mind you don't think we're all gonna
worry about now is there a second wave
you don't think we're all gonna worry
about now when somebody sneezes in Asia
how long until that cold comes here no
but I would not zero I don't know that
we ever get back to zero
dr. you want to mention some
I concur hospitals and queens but they
don't have the blood gas machines or
cartridges which are critical for
operating them
also if ventilators if hospitals do have
ventilators do they have enough
operational technicians to operate them
they do they have enough operational
technicians they must because somehow
they've been working I don't know what
the exact operating technician is for a
ventilator but I have not heard that I
talked to the I've talked to all the
hospitals every day for the past couple
of days to find out what's going on what
they need in the heads of the large
hospital systems nobody's mentioned that
to me we have over 100 hospitals on the
phone so what was the first part of your
question
blood gas machine cartridges doctors are
Carissa is an expert on blood gas
machine cartridge he gave me some for my
birthday last year actually he said just
in case I didn't know what he meant at
the time no I know I need give me a
ventilator this birthday so I'm gonna
put it all together those are the
supplies to run the point-of-care
testing which is a blood gas which the
lab tests that we do at the bedside and
if there is a decrease in supplies we
are looking into all of them to get them
to the hospitals that are needed I knew
what a blood gas cartridge was I just
wanted the doctors
what do we need these temporary
facilities what would it get based on
those numbers not for my ears not for my
fur you're right we are that's my whole
point
we're flattening the curve now below
projected piece because of our behavior
but again Jimmy it's you want to talk
about this in the retrospective there is
no retrospective you're in the middle of
it if you walk in front of traffic on
the way home yes you're young you may
have a different life expectancy based
on your action we are in the middle of
it I'm not going to say to any right now
you've seen a little flattening that's
all you've seen you've seen four or five
days of flattening oh it's flat no you
have four or five days of flattening you
couldn't have tomorrow morning we wake
up and the numbers back up so I'm not
willing to say because it's not true
that any of this is over or anything has
been accomplished because this is just a
small snapshot in time where we are at
this rate we are below projected numbers
there is no judge there is no new peak
projection listen to what I'm saying
nobody is saying we peaked
we are flatten the curve for this period
of time if you continue doing what
you're doing
might one think the flattening would
continue my one might think that but
nobody knows nobody knows in terms of
people that may have died at home and
not been diagnosed I think that's a very
real possibility
we're looking at other models of
counting but I don't know I have no idea
the question is if people died at home
might you not have those numbers because
they would only come from basically your
funeral home we're looking at other
models because right now most of the
data we have comes from hospitals and
major institutions nursing homes so
there could be a deviation no doubt
about that skew the measurements that
you guys have been doing on
hospitalizations if there have been that
many at home deaths that have not been
tallied and nobody says there have been
that many at home - Jesse where could
their yeah they've been well people have
said there may be people who have died
at home who have not been counted that
is a possibility right that would never
affect the hospitalization rate because
the hospitalization rate is the number
of people who walk into the hospital
right that is different than the number
of people who have passed away we're
dealing with this illness at home and
perhaps they had symptoms that would
have been treatable or they it would
have caused them to go to the hospital
so you know like it's it's confusing
because if people are in the hospitals
right but if someone's at home because
they can't go to the hospital well you
ought to you if someone who ever went to
the hospital and just stayed at home and
passed away at home they would never
show up in the hospitalization rate they
would show up in the number of deaths
there might be just this point there
might be a lag in the number of deaths
because we haven't fully aggregated all
the data from all the different sources
that's possible I don't know how it's
going to be meaningful statistically but
it's possible
tonight I'm certain governor there is a
an emergency room physician in New York
City who says he's seen a very high
percentage of patients maybe 70% died
who were put on ventilators he's
thinking the approach is all wrong we
need to rethink the protocol that these
patients might not need the ventilators
they might need oxygen instead so I
think I can't comment on exactly what
they're saying but the fact is when
someone shows up in the emergency room
there's a handful things that are going
to take place one is the oxygen is an
initial therapy that someone needs but
but the fact is that if someone's
respiratory status gets worse they're
going to need respiratory support the
real question may be is there other
interventions that one can do we are
looking at what other possible therapies
would be out there that could possibly
be given earlier and that's all
experimental so the issue with
ventilators in general is that if you if
someone goes on a ventilator and the
government is spoken about this before
about how long people stay on the
ventilator the longer you stay on the
ventilator you end up potentially
causing damage to lung it's a pressure
that's being pushed into your lungs and
you're constantly putting pressure into
those little air sacs in the lungs it
can damage them and the high levels of
oxygen also think damage your lungs but
the fact is it's what's called the
catch-22 in a lot of ways which which is
where you need the ventilator but if
you're on in a long time it can cause
harm that's where you try to get them
off as fast as possible
excuse me I can't comment on his case
but obviously because I don't know the
the information but when someone comes
in the initial thing to do is to give
someone oxygen by mass and if someone
gets worse than you end up in debating
them what's happen with these patients
is that they get they get worse
relatively quickly and so there's a lot
of interventions that have have to have
to happen relatively quickly as well I'm
not a medical doctor obviously but look
nobody wants to put people on the
ventilator I've discerned that much and
I think these you're right the
percentage of people who go on the
ventilator who never come off the
ventilator is incredibly high I've even
heard like closer to 80% I don't think
the ventilator is doing that I think
that's why they're on the ventilator
they're doing the ventilator is
basically a last resort so when they put
you on the ventilator it's because
everything else has failed and that's
why the mortality rate is so high on the
ventilator and that's what we're seeing
here that death rate is going up because
it's the people who've been on a
ventilator 7 days 10 days 15 days and
they're passing away so when we had that
big increase in hospitalizations about
10 days ago two weeks ago that big spike
in hospitalizations what we're seeing is
the people who went into the hospital on
that day ten days ago 12 days ago who
didn't get better who was put on a
ventilator is now passing away and
that's what's driving this death toll
and look the that number
what's even making it more depressing
and distressing that death toll probably
will be this high or near this high or
even higher for the next several days
because it's the coefficient of the high
hospitalization rate from two weeks ago
or so so when you get up tomorrow
morning the news could be just just as
bleak and that's why I'll end where I
started you know mixed emotions
we are flattening the curve thank God
thank God thank God thank God
and thank a lot of good people who have
been working very hard that is a moment
in time don't get complacent it's what
we're doing that's working keep doing it
that's the good news
and that good news has a big caveat
we're still in the midst of it don't get
complacent you start acting different
you'll see that number change in 27
minutes that's the good news the bad
news is we have had a record number of
deaths I mean I went through 9/11 I
thought in my lifetime I wouldn't have
to see anything like that again nothing
that bad nothing that tragic I remember
the number of funerals after 9/11 I
remember the grief after 9/11 that this
should literally eclipse that in terms
of numbers of of dead in this state it's
it's almost unimaginable to me then how
do you square those two things we're
making progress we lost more people than
ever before on a single day okay I'm
going to work thank you guys
[Music]
we are not building more we're still
maintaining them we are still in the mix
don't get over confident don't get
complacent we're still in the midst of
this this can still turn anyway from
Sunday in California a possible
consortium of to buy medical supplies I
have not talked to him about a possible
consortium but it's one of the things
the National Governors Association is
talking about because what we just went
through where states are competing with
other states it's made absolutely no
sense for anyone so a statewide
consortium would be a positive
alternative or a federal government that
did all of the purchasing instead Jesse
and they just gave to the states that
made him a multi-state in Georgia
federal government to purchase right
when I was in federal government FEMA
effectively was the shipping clerk they
did the purchasing they disseminated to
the states that's the simplest system
federal government on a federal disaster
between multiple states that's a federal
disaster
they are the purchasing entity they are
the master strategist for the operation
that's option is if the federal
government's not going to do it
option B let the states as a consortium
be a purchasing consortium that's what
the National Governors Association
conversation is because what happened
here where I placed a [ __ ] Chicago
places another big California places
another bed that's just madness talk to
you later thank you
you